who doesn't love a tasty tasty easter
egg and in a tv-series as deep and
buried is Game of Thrones there's been
plenty that have passed us by over the
years here are six of the best Game of
Thrones is so popular that of course
celebrities are going to be falling over
themselves to try and black a cameo slot
there's been plenty of musical guests
like the drummer from Coldplay drumming
at the red wedding sigur rós performing
at the purple wedding Snow Patrol's Gary
Lightbody singing a damn catchy version
of the bear and the maiden fair and fair
and various members of Mastodon playing
some wildlings in season six we've
already been treated to British screen
legends Kevin Eldon and Richard E grant
portraying actors in some sort of meta
cameo there are no small parts we all
know by now that you should never ever
trust Petyr Littlefinger Baelish but you
should at least listen to what he says
because sometimes he can predict things
with an uncanny accuracy in season four
he tells dear sweet Robin people died at
a dinner tables they die in their beds
they die squatting over their chamber
pots
therefore accurately predicting the
major deaths for that season
Joffrey Shae and of course Tywin
Lannister
we all know that the Iron Throne is made
up of thousands of swords or perhaps
it's less than 200 if Littlefinger's to
be believed I've counted huh I'm sure
you have either way some famous ones
have found their way onto the most
coveted seat in Westeros a lot of the
prop swords allegedly came from the
Orlando Bloom movie kingdom of heaven
but most notably is Glamdring Gandalf
blade from the Lord of the Rings Peter
Dinklage's turn as the ghost in destiny
may not have wowed scanning for the warp
drive bad news it's already in foreign
hands but there was a lovely nod to
Bungie shared well shooter in Game of
Thrones in the shape of this window
although I doubt they'll make such no
Maj in future now that dinklebot has
been completely replaced by prolific
video game voice actor Nolan North I'm a
ghost she's actually now on your ghost
and you well you've been dead long time
we may still not have the latest book in
the series the winds of winter but at
least it did get a nice little name drop
in season 6 episode 5 the door
I feel the winds of winter as they lick
across the land and our Sun alone on
that cold cold throne without a guiding
hand come on George
get it together one of the biggest fan
theories around is that Jon Snow's real
father is Rhaegar Targaryen who's
Daenerys his older brother and that his
mother is Lyanna stark Ned's sister our
Purcell equals J is one fan theory that
we're all just dying to be confirmed and
it seems like the TV shows writers are
just messing with us at Castle black way
back in season 1 we can see a young Jon
Snow standing next to two initials
carved into a wooden beam basically R
plus L equals J confirmed
which is your favorite game of thrones
easter-egg anymore that slipped through
the net let me know in the comments
below or come find me on Twitter I met
Lucy James games for more Westeros
action make sure to check out GameSpot
of Thrones every Monday at youtube.com
slash GameSpot all men must subscribe